all eyes are on the white house tonight
where joe biden just wrapped up another
week from hell
biden sloppy bizarre public comments
about russia ukraine well it could very
well lead to war we have over a hundred
thousand russian troops now amassed on
ukraine's border and biden proudly
suggesting that he might be willing to
look the other way if it's a minor
incursion in the past 48 hours multiple
white house officials they've all tried
to clean up those comments and joey's
mess it's so bad that apparently joe is
no longer allowed to even answer
questions about the looming conflict in
ukraine that he seemed to green light
take a look
the reason we're not going to have any
time for questions now is these guys got
to get quickly on the plane and go out
and do a major announcement in ohio and
you guys will ask me all about russia
and not about anything having to do with
chips
oh okay let's forget about the looming
global conflict in europe that you
greenlighted and biden will only
entertain
important questions on chips have any
chips that they could put in his head
maybe make them a little sharper i don't
know just kidding for those of you on
the left that have no sense of humor
anyway don't worry because this morning
well the chief idiot at the white house
ron klain oh he cleared everything up
take a look
i think it's fair to say the white house
is pretty aggressively walk back or
clarified whatever you want to call it
the president's comments about ukraine
and russia and whether the president was
signaling that a minor incursion
might be viewed through a different lens
whether the president meant to say that
at the time or maybe he was being
inarticulate can you afford any gaffes
given the stakes right now in all this
well i think the president was quite
clear and reiterated his point of view
this morning very clearly president
putin should have no doubt any move by
the russian assembled military across
the border of ukraine is an invasion
okay he wasn't clear he talked about a
minor incursion stop lying to us stop
the spin stop the propaganda you know
what uh the american people are
intelligent and as per usual biden
creates a crisis and then the white
house pretends that it is no crisis and
round and round we go and we see this at
the southern border we see it in
afghanistan yeah americans are still
abandoned trapped behind enemy lines and
we see this with inflation the supply
chain crisis we see it with covert 19.
by the way check out the cover time
magazine accurately pointing out biden's
first year is officially in the books
and a dark cloud hanging over the white
house really it's hanging over the
country remember the guy that promised
to shut down covert 19 rebuild our
economy
restored diplomacy and respect around
the globe well now covert 19 is raging
worse than ever inflation at a 40-year
high and war in europe thanks to him and
his green light is now pretty imminent
now things have become so bad under
biden that even gensake is now suggest
suggesting kickboxing or margaritas to
help ease the pain you're gonna need an
awful lot of margaritas take a look
but we've got to stay at it so my advice
to everyone out there who's frustrated
sad angry pissed off feel those emotions
go to a kickboxing class have a
margarita do whatever you need to do
this weekend and then wake up on monday
morning we gotta keep fighting
okay we'll drink margaritas all weekend
and act like it wasn't a disastrous week
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else